a stone is fired on a level floor so
that's convenient my diagram already
applies with initial speed V equals 10
and the angle is 45 degrees so that's
where expired on that that totally looks
like 45 degrees not okay hey find all of
these equations of motion right and then
by eliminating T should the equation of
the path is that now this is this is the
steps we just did but with concrete
numbers okay so just for the sake of
brevity you guys are you shouldn't skip
the constants when you're integrating
through but let's just do it a little
quicker just so that we can see what's
actually happening and do the more
interesting parts of the equation okay
so what do we like here
start off with your initial equations
for acceleration so these X double dot
no acceleration their accidents going to
be a constant but you already know what
constant that's going to be it's gonna
be the COS alpha v cos alpha now I know
of these and I know it offers so it's
going to be ten is my V cos alpha which
is 45 degrees okay so that's 10 over 2
which is 5 over 2
yeah ok great now we're gonna get your
grade again and because it's just a
constant you slap the T on there and
because I'm actually starting the origin
the constant is gonna be the second cost
that will also be zero I'm just gonna
leave that there
okay all right no vertically we're being
affected by gravity and I think they've
taken as minus ten yes
okay so therefore acceleration sorry
velocity that mine is tend to becomes
minus 10 T and then I'm gonna have my
plus V sine alpha okay now this is V cos
alcohol but because of this case being
45 degrees because alpha and B sine
alpha are going to be the same right so
this is just going to be 5 over 2
five your tools are really creepy none
of the guys for some reason wasn't could
be here but it's fire to become favorite
it all right now what we want is an
equation for y in terms of X only so
he's not eliminating the parameter step
yeah so therefore I'll come over here
and remember we're going to get tail
it's iron
so it's he is just equal to X on five or
two okay so now when I bring this over
on to this side just be careful with
brackets and so on I've got minus five
outside of X on fiber two squared right
plus five root 2 times X on fiber - okay
so you can see on that side that's a bit
easy that's just going to cancel motive
icky just to be cautious what you're
gonna get is 5 root 2 squared over 2
squared that's 25 times 2 so that's 50
right so therefore you're gonna get 5
minus minus 5 squared on 50 plus X and
there's the minus 1 over 10 that they
were looking for because it's actually a
known result now this is just the
factorized form of that this is what
1006
okay now look good
pate done papi
now here's where it starts to become
clear why is it useful to actually
eliminate the parameter okay
having that parameter time is useful
when you're asking questions of when am
I so answer or how long is it going to
take me to do blah blah blah
right so for instance how long does it
take for the shell to hit the target
okay but when you've got this kind of
equation here it's independent of time
so it's just about getting the
relationship between how high am i
versus how far I've traveled
horizontally okay and you can use the
quadratic theory that you've learned in
like nine and you tend to get some
really really easy numbers out of this
so for instance Part B says find the
range and the maximum height range in
excel file so range means this how far
is that what is it the start how far as
a stone get okay now when you think
about this as a parabola you're like
well that range is just the distance
between the roots right so you can read
that off right the roots are 0 and 10
okay so what I would actually say is by
quadratic theory
just to make it obvious where I'm
actually getting from like what pardon
quadratic theory and I getting it from I
put both roots there even though 10
minus 0 is trivial right but it shows
you I'm taking the difference between
those I'm not plugging a number out of
exactly so there's my range in a civil
way they say what's the maximum height
so that's going to be up here now
because you know it's a parabola right
you know that the maximum height you
don't have to differentiate it to find
where that is you just know it's halfway
between the roots upon the axis of
symmetry so you take the right value
namely 5 and you substitute in you say
max is equal to take your Y equation and
you shove in 5 if you like just put on
the side here x equals 5 even though it
should be fea clear from your
substitution there you're gonna have 1/2
times 5 so it's just kind of sweet right
none of this oh I have to work out what
Y is equal to work out velocities equal
to 0 yadda yadda yadda you just read off
the coordinates because you know how it
behaves cuz it's a parabola
Part C here's where they start to vary
things up suppose first that the stone
hits a wall 8 meters away so here's
where your diagram comes in right if you
hit this wall 8 meters away it's
obviously not going to get all the way
to when it's full range is it gets spots
short right so stick a wall in there
okay there's my wall and it's 8 meters
away so the first part of that question
I should write Part C Part one find how
far up the wall the stone hits okay then
just before we solve this think about
how you would do this without having
eliminated the parameter kind of tricky
actually you've got to go through a few
steps why be careful with your
horizontal velocity but here all I have
to do is take x equals a and sub it in
that's it so I say
equals a y is equal to a Don 10 times 10
minus 8 that's two that's going to
become 16 so it's 1.6 1.6 meters up ok
deformation equation of part and hence
by the angle of inclination when the
stone hits the wall ok let's think about
this the equation of path is this thing
I'm gonna go into that form rather than
the next one because I don't need to
it's easy to differentiate rather than
this factorized wall ok so I can say
part two the derivative of the equation
apart right dy/dx is equal to okay 2
comes out the front so that's going to
be minus 1 over 5x plus 1
there's the derivative ok so I'm
interested in what's not equal to at the
point of impact right so when x equals a
right dou Y DX is going to be let's see
minus 8 on 5 plus 1 which is minus 3
over 5 okay so that's the gradient at
that point if I were to draw a tangent
in there right its gradient will be
equal to minus 3/5 ok so if I want an
angle of inclination all I have to say
is M equals tan theta ok so theta will
be tan inverse of minus 3/5 ok and you
get an angle of inclination out of that
it's gonna be negative because it's it's
dropping down ok I'm not sure what the
actual decimal value is but people the
mechanics of actually getting this very
simple okay all right paddy supposed now
that the stone hits a ceiling 2.1 meters
five two point one meters just be
careful with your scale now as well as
this will be here we said that that top
point was two point five so i guess just
a little bit more like that will be
twofold
so there's my 2.1 beat-up ceiling okay
find the horizontal distance before
impact
horizontal this is before you bat so how
far is it going to travel before it
actually hits the ceiling right so
therefore to solve that because my line
up here is not just 2.1 it's y equals
2.5 so solving for the point of view
it's actually very simple y is equal to
two point one okay so therefore two
point one is equal to - what was it 1
over 10 which I think I had this okay so
I'm gonna multiply through by 10 to get
rid of that if you look at your decimal
value that gives me 21 is equal to minus
10x plus wait hold on that's a plus
that's better okay
but prevalence facing the right way now
so now put this all on one side so it's
nice and easy to factorize x squared
minus 10x plus 21 until the dome is
where after all three and seven or more
specifically negative 3 and negative
similar yeah that comes your two
solutions which is what you ought to
expect because all that thing was solved
this equation here right
so there's solution one and their
solution too ok now just like usual when
you get two solutions don't just ignore
my and B you know give it the give me
the silent treatment for no reason
you've actually got to say why you
disregard it okay so say as the stone
hits the ceiling
once right namely the first time okay
it's not gonna go through the ceiling q
creepy music and then hit the second
okay
therefore x equals three only right so
that was the first time I enter what was
that
horizontal distance x equals three and
then the second part of equation was
let's see it find the angle at which the
stone hits the ceiling so basically
you're going to rinse and repeat this
step here take your dream really pop in
x equals three and you'll get a
different angle at the end okay so you
can see the kinds of questions that you
do in the equation of path you could do
without having eliminated the parameter
but they're just more direct Thanks